6 14 on your monday morning you know in
our traffic reports we usually
concentrate on the freeways in your
morning commute but some closures
impacting the driving and around
downtown las vegas some of them are just
starting today but others well you know
they've been going on for quite a while
are bianca coleman live in the heart of
it all with what we need to know hey
bianca
hey good morning good morning everybody
at home one of the closures is starting
today it's here along california between
third and commerce here in downtown las
vegas this is a 3.8 million project
geared to help the traffic and
pedestrian flow throughout this corridor
along california and so we're talking
new pavement driveways trees and street
lights along california avenue
you can expect lane restrictions in this
area until the summer another closure we
want to share with you is las vegas
boulevard off ramp from southbound 5 15
95. now this coincides with the
reopening of casino center boulevard off
ramp from southbound 5 15 95. so what
they're doing here is the rehabilitation
of downtown las vegas viaduct and ramp
structures and that's been something
that's been ongoing we've talked about
in our traffic reports and that's a 40
million dollar rehab project
and it's about 33 percent complete so
still some ways to go there is another
closure that's starting today we're
going to let you know about that coming
up in about 30 minutes so be sure to
stick with us bianca holman live local
now